[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: I am pleased
to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Francis H. Duehay,
Mayor of the City of Cambridge.
It is also my pleasure to
welcome Raymond Magliozzi,
class of 1972, and Thomas
L. Magliozzi, class of '58,
hosts of the National Public
Radio series Car Talk.
[APPLAUSE]
The Magliozzi brothers will now
give the commencement address.
[APPLAUSE]
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Don't crowd me.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Glad you could all come.
[BLOWHORN]
Shut up.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
What's this?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Wait a minute.
I have to put my glasses
on and everything.
You're not supposed to start.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
When this was
announced in the newspaper--
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
This happens all the time.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: This was
announced in the newspaper.
And my daughter-- my
lovely daughter Lydia,
who's sitting over there--
called me and
said, is this true?
And I said, yeah.
She said, when is commencement?
I said, it's June the 4th.
She said, promise
me just one thing.
I said, what?
She says, promise me that you'll
think about it before June 3.
[LAUGHTER]
Which reminded me of that
great old country music
song, "How Come You
Know Me So Good When
I'm a Stranger to Myself."
Now, what do you want to say?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Well, not much actually.
I just wanted to
say, we are thrilled
to be here with you today.
And we especially want to
thank Dr. Vest and anyone else
that he might be able
to implicate for having
the courage to invite us here.
[CHEERING]
Now, I'm sure that--
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
We figure, this
is a guy who has an
ironclad contract.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, you got to
really have him.
Where is he?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Well, I'm sure
those of you that
know him know that he
is a take-charge,
buck-stops-here kind of guy.
I know that, because
every time his wife Becky
has taken her automobile
to our shop for repairs,
he calls personally to
complain about the bill.
And were flattered to find
out, I think just this morning,
that only once before in
the long history of MIT
has the demand for commencement
tickets been greater.
And coincidentally, it
was when Abraham Lincoln
spoke to my brother's
graduating class.
[LAUGHTER]
If anything ever cried
out for an explanation,
it's, why are Tom and
Ray speaking to us today?
And I will attempt, with
the help of my brother,
to give you some kind
of an explanation.
I think you deserve it.
Are you going to be good?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
I'm going to be good.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
This all started a little
over two years ago.
We were doing our
weekly radio show.
And I happened to
mention, casually,
that Kofi Annan
had been selected
to give the address
to the class of '97.
Tommy says, Kofi Annan?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Who the hell is he?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Whatever happened to Ooh fan?
And then he begins to rant,
why did they choose Kofi Annan?
Well, OK, he is the secretary
general of the UN, I guess.
But no one's ever heard of him.
Everyone's heard of us.
They've got to fly him in,
fly him out, put him up
in a fancy hotel, wine him
and dine him and do all that.
They'd have to do none
of these things for us.
And, and, and--
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: And what?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: And
he's not even an alumnus.
[CHEERING]
Now, I will admit that I did
participate, to some extent,
in his rant and rave.
I've learned, I guess
most of the experts agree,
that when you're dealing
with these irrational types
that you shouldn't be
too confrontational.
In fact, you should try
to be a little supportive,
and then hope the
medication kicks in.
Well, hardly a fortnight passes,
and we receive in the mail,
from someone named
Charles M. Vest, what
I would call a terse rebuke.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
It wasn't so terse.
I happen to have it here.
[LAUGHTER]
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Read it to us, please.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Which one is it?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
It's the first one.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Here it is.
Dear Click '58 and Clack '72--
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Aha,
now you know who we are.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: I was sorry
to learn of your disappointment
at not being--
you don't mind if we read this?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: We did
clear this with your office.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
What can he do.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm sorry to learn of
your disappointment
at not being asked to deliver
the main address at this year's
commencement exercise.
It had been my understanding
that you don't usually
care for exercise,
especially in the open air,
and that you therefore
wouldn't be interested in ours.
[LAUGHTER]
On the other hand, as alumnae--
I'm going with the Greco-Latin
pronunciation here.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: I think
Latin would be sufficient.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: On
the other hand, as alumnae,
you will appreciate
the fact that we
have some fairly eccentric
students and faculty here
at the Institute.
So the idea of having
you two gentlemen
as graduation speakers is
invariably floated each spring.
This year, as always, there was
a strong but murky undercurrent
of support for you as
commencement speakers.
Still, even your
most ardent backers
had to admit that there was
one crucial area in which
your qualifications
could not match
those of your fellow alumnus--
he is an alumnus.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
[CLEARS THROAT]
What does that say?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: It says,
of your fellow alumnus, UN
Secretary General Dag Hammars--
Kofi Annan, '72.
He was a classmate of yours.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
No, no, let's
get this straight right now.
I was class of '70, '71, '72.
So I couldn't possibly
have known everyone.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: No, OK.
As you know, the United Nations
has a really spiffy flag.
Because Secretary General Annan
was featured as this year's
speaker, we had a
legitimate excuse
to fly the UN flag on the
dais, and also to hang it
anywhere else we wanted to.
You can imagine how
useful such a flag
can be when you want to cheer
up a drab corner of the campus
or decorate a really big
space, like an auditorium
or an athletic cage.
These are the kind of criteria
that this guy Vest is using?
What the hell is he thinking?
If Car Talk, or even
Dewey, Cheetham, and Howe,
had possessed a similarly
attractive flag,
we might have been
able to use you.
But as it was, we
felt that we really
had to go with the secretary
general for aesthetic reasons.
Right.
You will be pleased to know,
however, that Secretary General
Annan was a great success.
The graduating seniors
were especially
moved when he described
his challenge at the UN
as, a little like try
trying to climb Mt.
Washington in a '63 Dodge Dart.
He was also warmly
applauded when
he urged the US
Senate to give him
their share of the gas money
for UN operations worldwide.
Thus, despite your absence,
MIT's '97 commencement
was a smashing success.
Please rest assured
we'll keep you
in mind for future
ceremonies, blah, blah, blah.
If you ever do get
a flag, let us know.
As you may recall from
your own graduations,
the participants
want the speakers
to be brief and to the point.
I know that brevity
is not regarded
as your most notable quality.
[LAUGHTER]
Finally, I would
like to urge you to--
here it comes.
All that for this last,
one-line ending paragraph.
Finally, I would like to
urge you to start sending out
some really large donations.
Technically yours, Charles M.
Vest, President, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Well, a whole year
passes without incident.
Well, I shouldn't
say without incident.
During that year, I think
just about every automaker
on the planet
threatened to sue us.
But at least without incident
with regard to this issue.
And then last year, Tommy hears
that some elected official--
these are his words, remember--
from Arkansas, who's
been in a little--
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
I don't think
I referred to him as
an elected official.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: --a
little trouble with the law
is going to give the
address of the class of '98.
As you can imagine,
another rant ensues.
Well, it doesn't take
long before Charles M.
Vest puts laser
printer to paper,
and we receive another rebuke.
I like the sound--
like a Bible story.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Which
I also happen to have here.
Chuck won't mind
if we read this.
"Dear Click '58 and Click '72,
I understand that you have,
once again, expressed
on-air disappointment
over not being asked to
speak at MIT's graduation.
Last summer, I advised
you that your chances
of being invited as
commencement speakers
would be enhanced
if Car Talk had
a suitable flag
that could be used
to help us decorate the campus.
I hear that you now have
come up with the flag,
and that you thought
this would assure
your inclusion in the
1998 commencement program.
We went out of our way.
If the truth be known, we
got the flag yesterday.
But we told him we had a flag.
We figured he would
be gullible enough--
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
He went for it.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Certainly it
is possible that a truly
elegant flag, along with you
are accountable yet
undeniable popularity
among your fellow alums
might have gone a long way
toward assuring a place for
you in this year's celebration,
except for two rather
obvious problems.
One, problem number
one, he says,
you failed to show your
new flag to anyone at MIT.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Minor detail.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Now, I don't
doubt that the flag exists.
Well, that's not
entirely accurate.
I do doubt the flag assists.
But its existence does you no
good if you keep it secret.
There is, after all, a reason
why people use expressions
like, let's run this up the
flagpole, blah, blah, blah.
And the reason is very simply
that people cannot appreciate
your flag unless
they can see it.
Now, some of my colleagues have
suggested that the Car Talk
flag may be based on
some sort of advanced
stealth technology,
in which case
I applaud your
technical prowess.
On the whole, however,
a stealth flag
seems to be a
self-defeating innovation.
And he's right about that.
Problem number two, one of this
year's commencement speakers
is the Honorable William
Jefferson Clinton, President
of these here United States.
I paraphrased there.
As the duly elected leader of
the world's only superpower,
Mr. Clinton not only
comes with his own flag,
and a darn good one, too.
But he's even got a seal.
Talk about upping the ante.
Heck, this guy brings his own
podium, audience, press corps,
helicopter, you name it.
There's just no way for the two
of you to compete this year.
You think you're disappointed?
Not even I get to make
a speech this year,
and I'm supposed
to run the place.
[LAUGHTER]
Nonetheless, he says, I urge
you not to give up hope.
Send us pictures of
this alleged flag,
along with appropriate
contributions to the alumni
fund.
Jeez, will the
guy never give up?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: He's
like a broken record, isn't he?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Good luck.
I remain technically
yours, Charles M. Vest.
We got another
letter, by the way.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
I'm getting to that.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Oh, you are?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Don't interrupt.
After these two
letters, of course,
Tommy continues to rant,
albeit sporadically.
He says, because we
haven't been chosen
and been overlooked by MIT,
he's lost face and credibility.
You'd want to lose a face
like this, wouldn't you?
Friends and neighbors have
turned a cold shoulder to him.
His wife and kids have
lost respect for him
and barely talk to him.
Even the dog won't play with
him unless he has a pork chop
tied around his neck.
Then in the spring of this
year, inexplicably, we
receive a beautifully written,
I would say almost conciliatory,
letter from Dr. Vest asking
us to speak to you today.
Of course, we lost that letter.
We don't know where it is.
But I do know that
Dr. Vest figured
that we would have the dignity,
the good sense, and the respect
for MIT to refuse, and to
realize that the invitation was
a joke.
Negative on all counts.
And of course, we become
immediately suspicious.
We start to think,
how many others were
asked before they got to us?
I mean, after all, we knew--
we're not kidding anyone--
we are at the
bottom of the heap.
Exactly right, we're at
the bottom of the heap.
So they must have asked
thousands of other people.
So we engage our
crack detective,
Paul Murky of Murky
Investigations,
to find out who was asked, and
the reason he or she refused.
I have the list.
Just stand back.
[LAUGHTER]
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: These
are the requests that he made?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Yes.
Now, due to certain
treaty restrictions
and other strict
protocols, and time,
we can't read all the names.
But we do have a few that
we're allowed to read.
And I will give you the name
of the person who was asked
and the reason.
My brother will give you the
reason he or she refused.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: I've
memorized the whole pile here.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
OK, Kofi Annan.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Yeah, he's
said, been there, done that.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Here's one.
Oh, a duo--
Pons and Fleischmann.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Yeah, they
said, very low energy level.
We can't do it.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Oh, one
of my personal favorites--
Leonid Brezhnev.
I love saying his name.
Can I say it again?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Is it like Arup Gupta?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Yeah.
Leonid Brezhnev.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Yeah, he said
he couldn't do it
because he was dead.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Let's see.
Oh, yes, Dolly the cloned sheep.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: She
couldn't come because she
didn't have FDA approval.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: And last
but not least, Leonid Brezhnev.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Still dead.
So then he got to us, I guess.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
I guess so.
But in spite of this news, we're
still excited and thrilled,
of course, and
honored to be here.
And after the
euphoria subsided, it
began to sink in
that we actually
had to give a speech today.
And I will admit
that I was concerned
to maybe even a bit worried.
After all, commencement
speeches are usually
reserved for heads of
state, respected members
of the academic
community, secretaries
general of the United Nations.
But us, why us?
But my fears began to ebb as
I weighed the consequences
of a poor performance today.
What if we do terribly?
What if we're incoherent,
uninspiring, uninteresting?
It'd be just like
our radio show.
I mean, what could
possibly happen?
What could they do, ask
for our diplomas back?
They couldn't do
that, could they?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
I don't think so.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: I don't
want to give my diploma back.
I can't.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
No, it's holding up
the end of that table
in your dining room.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Well, after this epiphany,
I began to feel a
lightness of being.
And Tom and I rolled
up our sleeves,
put on a pot of coffee, and
began the creative process.
Now, he'll devolve the
intricacies of that process
soon enough-- but
first, the warnings.
I have to move this.
[LAUGHTER]
What an interesting perspective.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
That's good.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
You know, my brother
frequently makes what I would
call offensive and insulting
statements.
So my main function here today,
other than introducing him,
is to, number one, deflect
any hurled fruit, number two,
to try to prevent him from
insulting any religious,
ethnic, or paramilitary groups,
to quell any civil unrest that
may result from anything
he says or does,
and to interrupt and clarify,
and say things like, well, he
didn't mean to say that about
every member of the faculty.
So without further
ado, I would like
to introduce my esteemed
brother, Professor Thomas
Magliozzi.
[APPLAUSE]
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
That would be me.
Well, we had to use
technology, actually.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: May I sit.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Aw, jeez.
We figured doing this at the
world's foremost institute
of technology on
Massachusetts Avenue,
and so we ought
to use technology.
So what my brother
did actually was,
he requested, from Paul
Parravano, who's, I guess,
the vice president of MIT.
Where is Paul?
We don't know.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
They threw him out.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: He
requested copies of the last 20
years commencement addresses.
We gave this to our
crack researcher,
Paul Murky of Murky
Research, brother of the Paul
Murky of Murky Investigations.
And we asked him to analyze
all of these speeches
to find out if there
were some commonalities.
And indeed, there were.
He used factor analysis,
which, of course,
15 guys will understand.
And he came up
with three factors.
Well, get this.
Every one of these speeches
had in common a beginning,
a middle, and an end.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Wow, powerful.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Well, this is good.
Because we were so
thrilled at this,
that we had made such
progress, that we put it
aside for about a month.
We didn't have to
think about it anymore.
Then we looked at it one day and
said, this is a little skimpy.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
I hate to interrupt.
But the good news is, our wives
are not hanging their heads
in shame yet.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: They will.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
OK, go ahead.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: We
figured, the beginning, that
was pretty straightforward.
We could read a couple of
letters from Chuck Vest.
So we did that already,
and so that's done.
The middle, that
was the tough part.
We couldn't quite figure
what the middle ought to be.
But the end, we knew,
had to be some kind
of inspirational thing.
That's what they all are.
So we said to ourselves,
what do we know
about inspirational things?
It so happens, however--
man, it so happens that
we have, in addition
to Murky Investigations,
Paul Murky,
whom I just told you
did the factor analysis,
had been working on some
other research for us.
And he and his lovely
assistant Marge Innovera--
Marge Innovera.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Yeah, they got it, I think.
It just wasn't that funny.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: I'll
tell you the genesis.
It's interesting how
research happens.
One day, I can't
remember which one of us
it was, had come
across, interestingly--
isn't it interesting?
I mean, coincidence-- we just
had a little Hebrew prayer.
And one of us had
thought of a quotation
from one of another great Hebrew
philosopher, Isaac Newton.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you recall--
which you probably
don't, because you're
a bunch of nerds who
only think in numbers.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Stop it.
Behave.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: He said,
if I have accomplished anything
in my life, it is
because I have stood
on the shoulders of giants.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Wow.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
That's what we said, wow.
But after a few moments,
we thought about it a bit
and said, it's one of
those things-- you know,
like George Carlin, he
says, sounds good, but--
and we wondered, is it in fact
true in all areas of endeavor
that people accomplish great
things because they stand
on the shoulders of giants?
So we tell Paul Murky,
do some research on this.
And he comes back to us
with a couple of hypotheses.
He's a great
researcher, this man.
The null hypothesis
is, well, of course
it applies to all areas
and all endeavors.
Because we, as humans,
have been on the planet
for hundreds of
thousands of years.
And we each benefit
from whatever has
been done by our predecessors.
That's the shoulders
of giants hypothesis.
The alternative
hypothesis is, oh, yeah?
The alternative hypothesis
is, it's not true.
In some areas, yes,
we do, in fact,
benefit from what our
predecessors have done.
But in other areas, mostly
the human involvement kinds
of areas, we may,
in fact, all be
destined to make the same
mistakes over and over
and over again, generation after
generation, child after child.
And so there is never any
giant on whose shoulders
you could stand.
And therefore, there
is no progress.
There is an interesting
set of hypotheses.
This one is called the "oh
yeah" alternative hypothesis.
So Murky goes out
and starts to work.
And as he will do, Murky
doesn't stick strictly
to what we asked him to do.
And one day, we
catch him, I think
it's called mucking
around in the data.
And sure enough, he
comes to us and says,
guys, I have been mucking
around in the data.
And I have a
finding here that is
going to knock your socks off.
And I have to apologize
for our visual aids here.
I did prepare a complete
PowerPoint presentation.
And I asked for an
overhead projector,
and they couldn't find one here.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
No, I think
they told him to drop dead.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Could I
have a slide number two please?
Come on, Chuck.
Earn your buck here.
Earn your money, number two.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: What's
the matter with number one?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: I
already used that one.
[LAUGHTER]
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Should we turn it around
so people behind us can see?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Yeah, just
turn it around for a minute.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
We'll be right back.
[LAUGHTER]
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Don't
fall off the stage, Chuck.
Now, those in the back
with the cheap seats,
you can't see this.
But it's very straightforward.
I may have to move
over to this mic.
Does this mic work?
Yes, it does.
Murky says to us, I've plotted
something interesting here.
We're talking about, basically,
left brain versus right brain
function.
He says, and while
mucking around,
I find this interesting
relationship.
This is left brain on this end.
This is a right
brain on the right.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
And what's the y-axis?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Well, I'll tell you that.
This is a plot--
he did a regression analysis on
this with an R square of 0.99
and a significance of 0.001.
[LAUGHTER]
And this, this
axis is happiness.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Whoa.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Doesn't
that knock your socks off?
He says, left
brain, right brain.
And if you think about it, this
is sort of what we think of--
some people do at
least-- intelligence.
So it's almost a plot of
intelligence versus happiness.
And the news ain't good for you.
[LAUGHTER]
Because what Murky finds out
is that right-brained people
are about 10 times as happy
as left-brained people.
So the stupider you get--
by left-brained
people's measures
of stupidity, of course.
Because right-brained people
are too happy to waste
their time developing IQ tests.
But they're 10 times happier.
We say, woof, Paul,
this is something.
But that's not the end of it.
Because we do what any
good researcher would do.
We want to extrapolate.
And do we want to extrapolate
in this direction?
Hell, no.
[LAUGHTER]
We want to extrapolate
in that direction.
So we say to Paul,
if this really
is intelligence going
in that direction, what
we need is dumber people.
Let's see if it goes on and on.
So where do you go?
He goes to Harvard.
[LAUGHTER]
He comes back to us
about a month later.
And he says, it
just isn't working.
He said, they're
not dumb enough.
And I say, what do you mean
they're not dumb enough?
They don't get any dumber
than Harvard students.
And he says, people
don't get any dumber
than Harvard students.
But why do we have to limit
our research to people?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Can we put this down?
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Oh, sure.
Are you still there.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm just trying to drive the
guy with the microphones crazy.
No, don't go away.
We're going to
need number three.
He says, I can
extend the research
to include other life forms.
And through a methodology,
which he will not reveal to us,
he was able to determine the
happiness level of other life
forms.
Slide three, please.
Three, slide three.
Here it is.
Here's humans.
And the best of
humans, of course,
is the right-brained humans.
And here is what he found.
Happiness goes up.
It begins to look like it's
exponential over there.
The next happier life form
is a golden retriever.
[LAUGHTER]
Then a cow, then worms, and he
stopped his research at grass.
You can turn that to show the
faculty, because they may not
understand what
I'm talking about.
Now--
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: OK,
we'll just keep going.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Here's the story.
What is the importance of this?
We have always thought that
we were the highest life
form on the planet.
It turns out we are the lowest
life form on the planet.
And I am going to give to
you now a theorem which
will knock your socks off.
Some theories you know are
just complete bullshit--
for example, the
Big Bang Theory?
[LAUGHTER]
The entire universe is
compacted into a dot.
It explodes.
Why?
Well, they don't know why, so
they call it a singularity.
That's like a bimbo
saying, well, it just did.
It explodes.
And out of it come
all the stars that you
can see in the sky, all
the planets, Madonna--
[LAUGHTER]---- corned
beef sandwiches.
Now, if you didn't hear
that and say, oh, come on--
but I am going to
give you the theorem,
and you're going to say,
why didn't I think of that?
What does all of this tell us?
That we are not the
highest life form.
This is the theory of
reverse incarnation.
Some people believe
in reincarnation.
And what they believe
is that, when we die,
we come back as better
and better people.
What the theory of
reverse reincarnation
says, if we are good
people, we will come back
as a golden retriever--
[LAUGHTER]---- then a cow,
then a worm, then grass.
Now, if the reincarnation was
working in the other direction,
coming back as better and
better people, where are they?
[LAUGHTER]
Duh.
So it becomes clear that the
theory of reverse reincarnation
may be the scientific finding
of, not the decade, not the
century, but of all time.
Now, my brother and
I, L. Ron Magliozzi,
are going to help you
to achieve nirvana.
We're going to help you to
get to become not smarter--
smarter is no good.
That's the wrong direction.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
You've been doing that.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: You have
spent the last four, five,
or six years of your life
working on the wrong direction.
You are sliding down, as Tom
Lehrer says, sliding down
the razor blade of life.
You are sliding down
the happiness curve.
You must stop this
from happening,
and you must go in
the other direction.
And we are here to help you.
And as you know, there is a
process for reaching nirvana,
and we are going to
give it to you now.
It is this.
You must repeat the mantra.
And the mantra, which happens
to be emblazoned on our flag,
which stands here--
none of you morons
will be able to read it
because it's in Latin.
[LAUGHTER]
It says, non impediti
ratione cogitatonis.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Which of course means,
unencumbered by the
thought process.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING]
Now, I am going to give you
a very brief history of how
this mantra has helped me.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
I can't wait.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
If you repeat
this mantra, what happens
is, everything slows down.
Life slows down.
Being unencumbered by
the thought process
allows you to identify and
hear and see defining moments
in your life, things that
will change your life.
Unencumbered by the
thought process--
you say it over and over again.
And as everything slows
down and begins to stop,
we call these, by the
way, moments of inertia.
[LAUGHTER]
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Oh, god, is that bad.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: I
had to use it, though.
I had to.
I was once trapped by
the scientific logic,
left-brain life.
I graduated from here, and I
went to work as an engineer.
And I will tell you
about my defining moment.
I was driving.
I lived in Cambridge
at the time.
I was driving from
Cambridge to my job
in Foxboro, Massachusetts.
And I was driving
in a little MG.
It weighed about 50 pounds.
And on Route 128, I
was cut off by a semi.
And I almost, as they
say, bought the farm.
And as I continued my
drive, I said to myself,
if I had, in fact, bought the
farm out there on Route 128,
how ticked off would I be that
I had spent all of my life,
that I can remember, at
least, going to this job,
living a life of
quiet desperation?
So I pulled into
the parking lot,
walked into my boss's office.
And I quit on the spot.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
See now, most people
would have just
bought a bigger car.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: [LAUGHS]
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
So act now.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Yeah, see?
But those people would have
been using their left brains.
I had been saying my
mantra in the car.
That's why the guy cut me off.
I think I cut him off.
In any event, I quit my job.
I became a bum.
I spent two years sitting in
Harvard Square drinking coffee.
I invented the concept of the
do-it-yourself auto repair
shop, and I met my lovely
wife, none of which
would have happened if I had
been using my left brain.
My second great
defining moment came,
also showing the
power of the mantra,
unencumbered by the
thought process.
I was having an argument
with my lovely wife one day.
I mean, how can you argue
with such a wonderful person?
Well, left-brained
people do that.
Because all they can think
of is, this is an argument.
This person is over
here, and I'm over here.
And I am going to use every
ounce of logic and skill
that I have so that I
can win this argument.
And my wife says
to me, do you want
to be right or do
you want to be happy?
Holy shit, says I.
[LAUGHTER]
I wanted to be happy.
So now I have reached nirvana.
And my brother and I can
help you to reach it,
if you want to repeat after me.
Unencumbered by the
thought process.
Say it.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: You
may have to stand for this.
RAYMOND AND THOMAS
MAGLIOZZI: Unencumbered
by the thought process.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Louder, come on.
Unencumbered by the
thought process!
One more time.
Unencumbered by the
thought process!
Follow us, my
children, to happiness.
[LAUGHTER]
Are there any questions?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Thank you.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
Are you happy?
I'm
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Excited.
Thank you, Professor Wagstaff.
That was most informative.
That does remind me of a
famous Latin expression.
[SPEAKING LATIN]
Which means, if
Caesar were alive,
you'd be chained to an oar.
[LAUGHTER]
Look, we won't belabor this
any more than we have to.
But this is the part
of the address where
we're supposed to say
something meaningful
and impart some words of wisdom.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
What did I just do?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
We're not sure.
But I'm not sure that we're
in possession of any wisdom,
but we've never
let that stop us.
So listen up.
I'm only going to
say this a few times.
Today you will
receive a document
that states that you've earned
a degree, or maybe degrees,
from MIT.
You've worked hard, and you
should feel a great sense
of accomplishment.
I know I did.
And most of you will
leave here today
with a pretty good idea
of where you're going
and what you're going to do.
Some of you have no clue.
And you'll just have to move
back in with your parents,
if they haven't rented
out your room already.
[LAUGHTER]
But others among you may
have chartered a course
or had one chartered for
you that you know is wrong.
And you may feel some
creative energy coursing
through your body.
Don't ignore it.
If you feel the urge
to create and discover
and to do something
that will bring
you fulfillment and happiness,
do it now while you're young.
You will never have more energy
or enthusiasm, hair, or brain
cells than you have today.
Do you know, when
Albert Einstein was
less than half my
age, he was already
world famous for his special
theory of relativity?
When Isaac Newton was
less than half my age,
he was already famous for
having invented calculus.
And he pretty much had written
your entire 801 physics
textbook.
Mozart when he was
half my brother's age
had been dead for three years.
[LAUGHTER]
So act now.
Lastly, I've skipped a
bunch of things because--
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Thank God.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
I just want
to encourage you to never get so
involved in your work, whatever
it is, that you
forget to have fun.
You know, my brother
may be right.
If you're lucky, you may come
back as a schnauzer or a bichon
frise.
But you may not.
With all this spaying
and neutering going on,
the odds are getting worse
and worse every year.
So have fun now
and enjoy yourself.
And I'd like to leave
you with some words
of a wise man, a wise man from
the east my brother and I know.
All wise men are from the east.
Have you ever met a wise man
from the west or the middle?
They're all from the east.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: I think
Spielberg's from the west.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: And
this wise man is no exception,
except he's from East Boston.
And his name is
Depak Fonzarelli.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
He's quite a man.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
He is quite a man.
And Tommy and I go
to him from time
to time to learn the answers
to weighty questions,
like, what is the
meaning of life?
What are next week's winning
lottery numbers going to be?
And we went to him recently,
and Tommy and I sat with him.
And Tommy asked him how he
could attain immortality.
Depak sat for a minute.
He got up and turned off the TV.
Baywatch had just ended.
And he said, my son, if you
wish to attain immortality,
you must do the following.
You must work hard every
day, seven days a week,
never taking time off.
You must the attend
no social functions.
You must not smoke,
you must not drink,
and you must not go with women.
Never had we received
such a definitive answer
to any of our questions.
We were astounded.
And Tommy asked--
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI:
I say to Depak,
you mean if I do those
things, I will live forever?
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI:
Oh, no, my son, he said,
it will just seem like forever.
[LAUGHTER]
Have fun, enjoy the ride, and
don't drive like my brother.
Congratulations.
THOMAS F. MAGLIOZZI: Don't
drive like my brother.
RAYMOND L. MAGLIOZZI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]